δε θεωρώ ότισωτατα περισσότεροσης α πόκατο πάρτη πο γίνότα δεν θεωρώ ότι υπήρξε υπουργός γεοργείας
υπήρξενάνθρωπος που είναι στη θέση που εγώ πυ είναι σήμερα που δεν θα ήθελα δεν
είναιι δε θεωρώ ότιείναι τάη είναι θέμα τόλες αυτές οι διαδικασίες έχουν άμεση σχέση και
το τιδι θλη τι αγορά και το πιοι είναι ιόροι που βάλισε σενδεχομένωση τις συμπσει
εμείς εκάμαμε και τούτι είναι διαφορά που κάμεν το γεννικό λόγιστήρα εκάναμε εμπρώτα διαβούλευση με
την αγορά δηλαή ρωτήσαμε την αγορά θέλουμε τούτα τα ταψητικά με έσα πότε μπορείτ πως
μπορείται και τα λιπά οπότα δημοηργήθηκε να αυτή διαδικασία του πάρξες λίζει που εντουδόσ ο
διαγωνισμός που υπάρχει αυτή τη στιγμή δηλαδή μας δίνουν τατα τρία ξεκινούν μετατρία έχουμε προέρεση
συμπνται το οποία να έρθουε μετά και εξεκινούμεν ανάλογα με τις δυνατότητες του της της
εταιρείας δεν ταταπτητικά μέσα μαζί με το πλήρομα για κάποιο χρομικό επιάσε μέχρι να έκπαιδεύση
τους δικούς μας παι προχωρούμε ποσόνα τιμμαστε για οσκαλο κερνούς μήνες λόγω γιατη δεν έβρεχε
έροναι πολύ ξερασία πως όνα τιμ είμαστε για να μη δούμε ικόνες φου βλέπο με
τα προγούμενα θρονια ξε το το ότι θα έχουμε πύρκαγές αυτό είναι ένα δεδομένο πάντα
υπάρχει εμείς είμαστε σε καλύτερι κατάσταση να πό ότι είμαστε πέρσε υποποία νανια έχουμε νιδηδιο
σητικάμέσα εδώ έχουν ίδη φτάσει είδαν κάτι το οποίο ζήτις ανα γίνει αποπέρσει όπου τους
είπα ενώ πέρσε ξεκινήσαμε τον απρήλιον την αντιπηρική περίοδο τους είπα θέτος θα ξηνήσουμε από
τον μάρτιο και όντωσε προχωρήσαμε με τοτιμα δασον και την έθνη και φρορά οπό άρα
έχουν α οιδιέρθει δύο ι ορδανικά τον επόμενο μήνα έρχονται αλλά